>> Tucker: ACCORDING TO
THE ENERGY INFORMATION
ADMINISTRATION, THE UNITED
STATES IS ABOUT TO RUN OUT
OF DIESEL FUEL.
SUPPLY OF DIESEL WILL BE
EXHAUSTED IN LESS THAN A
MONTH.
WHAT WILL THAT MEAN
EXACTLY?
CURRENTLY SEVEN STATES ARE
AT, QUOTE, ALERT LEVEL
FOUR.
THE SOUTHEAST IN CODE RED.
THAT MEANS 72 HOUR NOTICE
REQUIRED FOR ALL FUEL
DELIVERY IN ANTICIPATION
OF SHORTAGES.
DIESEL SHORTAGE IS A
SYMPTOM OF A LARGER
PROBLEM, DISTILL ATS,
INCLUDING JET FUEL, AND
LOWEST RECORDED LEVELS IN
MORE THAN A DECADE.
THERE ARE A LOT OF REASONS
FOR THIS.
THE BIDEN WAR AGAINST
RUSSIA IS THE MAIN ONE.
BUT THE EFFECT ON THE
COUNTRY, THAT'S THE
QUESTION TONIGHT.
WHAT WILL THAT MEAN IF WE
RUN OUT OF DISTILLATES IN
THE MIDDLE OF WINTER.
MIKE TAYLOR FROM ENERGY
SERVICES JOINS US.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
SO WHAT WILL THAT LOOK
LIKE EXACTLY?
>> WELL, TUCKER, I AM
HEARING FROM SUPPLIERS
THAT SEEMS LIKE WE'RE
WALKING A FINE TIGHT ROPE
ON HOME HEATING OIL AND
DIESEL SUPPLY.
I CAN ONLY SPEAK TO THE
NORTHEAST.
THEY'RE TELLING ME IN
RESERVES WE'RE AT 60% OF A
FIVE YEAR AVERAGE.
ALL OUR HEATING OIL, MOST
OF IT COMES FROM
PHILADELPHIA MARKET, LYNN
DEN, NEW JERSEY.
GOOD NEWS, A REFINERY IN
NEW JERSEY IS COMING BACK
ONLINE, PRODUCES 105
MILLION BARRELS A DAY.
THAT WILL HELP THE
NORTHEAST.
ALL THE OIL COMES OUT OF
THAT REGION FLOATS THROUGH
THE NEW YORK HARBOR AND
SUPPLIES NEW ENGLAND.
WE'VE SEEN SHORTAGES IN
EARLY ON OCTOBER.
SUPPLIERS ARE SAYING IT IS
A FINE TIGHT ROPE IF WE
HAVE A DRASTICALLY COLD
WINTER COULD BE TROUBLE.
>> Tucker: COULD BE
TROUBLE IN THE RICHEST
DEVELOPED NATION IN THE
WORLD, AFRAID OF WINTER.
WHAT WILL THAT MEAN FOR
PRICES FOR HEATING OIL AND
KEROSENE WHICH A LOT OF
PEOPLE USE IN TRAILERS,
WHAT WILL THAT LOOK LIKE
IN FEBRUARY?
>> NO QUESTION ALREADY
WE'VE SEEN HOME HEATING
OIL UP 3.50 A GALLON.
RETAIL HOME HEATING IS
OVER $6 A GALLON.
KEROSENE WHEN WE GET IT IS
AT 7.
AS WE HAVE SPOKEN, MOBILE
HOMES USE KEROSENE, IT IS
HARD TO GET AND WILL BE
UNAFFORDABLE.
CLIMATE CHANGE AGENDA IN
THE NORTHEAST IS WHAT'S
CAUSING THIS.
ACROSS THE COUNTRY
DEMONIZATION OF FOSSIL
FUELS.
BUT IN NEW YORK STATE, NEW
JERSEY, WE'RE ON FAST
TRACK TO ELIMINATE FOSSIL
FUELS WITH NO ALTERNATIVES
ANYBODY CAN AFFORD.
I DON'T KNOW IF WE TOLD
YOU --
>> PRICE OF CORD WOOD GOES
UP.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
IN NEW YORK STATE, THEY
OUTLAWED NATURAL GAS,
HEATING GAS, APPLIANCES IN
THE HOME.
NEW JERSEY OUTLAWING
BOILERS IN 2025.
ANY BOILER, 1 MILLION BTUs
AND UP, NATURAL GAS AND
HEATING OIL SYSTEMS, THERE
ARE 8300 OF THEM HAVE TO
CONVERT TO ELECTRICITY.
TUCKER, NEW JERSEY
ESTIMATED IT WILL COST
OVER $2 MILLION TO CONVERT
EACH OF THESE BUILDINGS
AND ADMITTED WITH
OPERATING COST FIVE TO SIX
TIMES USING ELECTRICITY
OVER NATURAL GAS.
CRASH COURSE WE ARE ON